pense donc avec le break site pour nous
intéresser aux cas de boris johnson
savait que les conservateurs se cherche
un leader et celui ci sera
automatiquement ça se passe comme ça en
angleterre le prochain premier ministre
johnson est favori et évidemment on
s'interroge sur son programme pour gérer
le break site et bien voici un début de
réponse cette tête dans une interview à
la radio nbc dans les abris qu'ils
cherchent de quoi ils jouent de chengdu
et philippe talent commence par vous ça
vous surprend pas est ce que boris
johnson et et est optimiste volontariste
ou est ce que quand il dit bah si on n'a
pas d'accord c'est pas grave
avec l'union européenne il est carrément
dangereux
je pense que il est obnubilé par lui
même et là une seule envie c'est de
devenir premier ministre et il va dire
ce que les gens ont envie d'entendre
mais quand vous écoutez cet entretien un
si long temps d'écouter la totalité ça
dure une demi-heure en soit le blessé
était hier matin et il ne dit rien il ne
répond à aucune question
alors c'est très vague vous avez vu dans
cet extrait est il dit bon il faut qu'on
arrête d'être pessimiste en a des
possibilités mais il explique pas
comment ils expliquent pas vraiment ce
qu'il va faire il a une façon de tourner
autour du pot pour endormir les gens qui
marchent à merveille et qu'il est
convaincu lui même de ce qu'ils pensent
et ils ne répondent pas aux questions et
c'est ça pour moi qui est le plus
troublant avec pollution mais il est en
coupe et que ça qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
sondage de yougov qui est un sondeur du
gouvernement britannique qui a trouvé
que 73 pour sont des conservateurs en
grande bretagne
se fiche du fait que si la
grande-bretagne pas de 31 octobre et
l'économie est gravement affectées bah
c'est pas grave il faut qu'on parte le
31 octobre
et c'est tout et c'est ce qui est dit
pollution ne sait pas ce qu'il veut
faire
est ce que c'est parce que ils le
cachent aux anglais ou est ce que parce
qu'il ne sait pas ce qui va changer je
pense que il a une vague idée dans sa
tête de ce qu'ils voudraient faire il
il est il est clair sur une chose il va
déchirer la cokerie sommet a négocié
avec l'union européenne ça n'existera
plus est il convaincu aussi qui va
retourner à bruxelles pour négocier un
nouvel accord avec l'union européenne et
limon très bien j'y vais nous sommes
dans une position de force
on va nécessairement réaliser un nouvel
accord avec l'union européenne il n'y a
pas de problème et donc on partira avec
un accord le 31 octobre
mais si jamais il nous n'arrivons pas eh
ben c'est pas bien grave on partir de
toute manière le 30 octobre et on
tombera sous les lois de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce et en continuant
très bien mais ce qui dit pas c'est que
tous les traités qui ont été négociés
avec l'union européenne vont tomber à
plat il faut tourner gosset et on n'aura
eu qu'une période de d'adaptation qui
prévu dans l'accord de tourisme et
jusqu'à la fin de 2021 pour pour y
arriver du jour au lendemain on n'a plus
rien donc c'est ça ce qui est le plus
inquiétant pour l'action et juste pour
terminer c'est guère mieux on fasse avec
jeremy hunt qui est aussi déterminé que
boris johnson pour sortir de l'union
européenne autre candidat conservateur
c'est un dieu derrière lui voilà et donc
on saura le 23 juillet
qui des deux va être le prochain premier
ministre mais lui il dit bon tube néon
portait un au turn to pas le problème
mais bon évidemment si on est sur le
point de négocier quelque chose de
meilleur
bon là j'attendais un petit peu je suis
prêt à prolonger de la tête alors que
pollution de samuel 31 octobre
ça a pris en main l'équipe bon ça va
alors on a posé la question à nos
internautes boris johnson vous
inquiète-t-il ben vous avez pas vraiment
d'avis ou plutôt vous êtes très partagés
puisque ses 51 49
alors on se tourne vers christian
makarian quand on sait à quel point il
connaît bien les affaires
internationales pour savoir si l'ue est
inquiet ou pas
donc je ne suis pas inquiet parce que je
tiens d'une confidence en tête à tête de
maure johnson que j'ai rencontré une
fois à paris la phrase suivante qui me
fait penser d'ailleurs à d'autres nous
étions dans un dîner puis on s'est isolé
un petit moment et comme je le harcelé
de questions
c'était il ya quelques années lors de la
parution de son livre consacré à
churchill l'édition française il ya déjà
c'était donc avant le référendum
peu avant et il me dit vous semblait
inquiet de façon la recroiser
aristocratique vous semblez inquiets
cher ami de tout cela vous est posée
tant de questions oui oui je suis
inquiet parce que j'aime beaucoup
l'angleterre et que j'ai pas envie de la
voir quitter l'union européenne imedi il
m'a répondu non mais dans le loiret des
six not going to happen
ça ne va pas arriver et ça me fait
penser à la phrase qui est rapporté dans
une biographie de trump on le sait très
bien les très célèbres ou trump 10 est à
un moment de la campagne électorale ou
tout début de toute façon je ne serai
pas élu tout ça c'est très bon pour moi
et toute façon je passerai pas et bien
trempé passé et boys johnson s'apprête
aide investit donc il y a là un côté
joueurs si vous voulez gamme blur qui
est quand même assez caractéristique du
personnage une formation non c'est pas
rassurant mais là où je suis je suis pas
inquiet c'est que il y a une cohérence
du côté européen c'est à dire qu'on ne
va pas renégocié il peut raconter ce
qu'il veut monsieur johnson on ne va pas
refaire un accord global avec le royaume
uni et donc c'est monsieur johnson qui
pliera le genou au final je crois qu'il
faut que les britanniques se retirent à
ce stade non pas parce que je le
souhaite mais parce que de toute
évidence c'est la seule le seul moyen de
crever l'abcès et de résoudre le débat
qui a lieu chez eux ou bien monsieur
johnson parvient à une situation moins
catastrophique
ou bien tout simplement il y aura je
parle sous le contrôle de philippe des
élections générales anticipées
nouveau voilà qui consacreront cette
fois la liquidation du parti
conservateur est également du parti
travailliste et en aura au royaume uni
comme on l'a eu en france avec la
liquidation de la gauche et de la droite
comme c'est déjà largement amorcée en
allemagne comme sur tulle ce fut le cas
en italie comme c'est le cas aux
pays-bas comme c'est le cas en belgique
alors à l'émiettement du paysage
politique du 19e siècle un peu partout
c'est le cas et dans ce cas là on pourra
reparler
donc quelque part je ne m'inquiète pas
maxis veille vous réalisez bien au
royaume uni c'est oui je me suis dit moi
je rescapés du mexique survenue ici à
cause du rexy tu exactement vous avez
vécu longtemps cas j'ai vécu en tout
cinq ans et je suis je suis plutôt
inquiet oui devant johnson arrivé au
terme d'un exploit parce que pour moi ce
côté joueurs ce côté indécis ils le
portent bien
il ne répond pas effectivement aux
questions il veut renégocier un accord
qui n'est pas renégocié a donc c'est
très bien que l'europe n'a aucune envie
de rouvrir l'accord de divorce qui a
pris tant de temps à être mis sur la
table avec tout le monde autour qu'ils
soient d'accord et donc en fait qu'on
lui pose la question de savoir comment
on va le faire
il est vague le problème c'est que moi
je pense qu'il ya un déni de réalité de
la part de boris johnson parce qu'il va
devoir régler une équation que theresa
may n'a pas pu régler et que lui ne
pourra pas régler non plus finalement
le royaume uni a décidé de sortir de
l'union européenne mais il ne sait pas
comment le faire et vous avez le legwork
est complètement divisé le parti
conservateur qui est complètement divisé
le parlement britannique est
complètement 10 est le pays qui divisait
lots fièrement vous tirer la couverture
d'un côté ce qui va faire c'est que les
conservateurs beaucoup plus break sitter
beaucoup plus on va dire extrême pour
une sortie voix très content vont voter
pour lui mais tous les modérés et tous
ceux qui veulent rester dans l'union
européenne ou au moins avoir un accord
peut-être d'union douanière ou le reste
est en marche et unique ne vont pas le
suivre et donc il va se retrouvent avec
le même problème il n'aura pas de
majorité au parlement
effectivement il y aura probablement des
élections anticipées moi je pense aussi
que ce scénario est très probable il ya
quand même quelque chose de très
intéressant avec blaise 25 c'est la
première fois depuis le vote du break
site qu'un briques sitter est au pouvoir
c'est à dire que jusqu'à présent
theresa may elle faisait ce qu'elle
pouvait alors s'est opposé aux grecs
français
elle devait gérer les affaires courantes
bon an mal an l'un boris johnson a fait
campagne pour le mexique avec beaucoup
d'arguments très fallacieux d'ailleurs
comme maintenant on voit qu'ils sont
vraiment mensongers et aujourd'hui il
est mis face à ses responsabilités ça
quelque part je trouve ça plutôt bien
le problème c'est que la perspective
d'un no deal donc le fait de sortir le
31 octobre de l'union européenne sans
aucun l'accord est de plus en plus
probable et je pense que les
conséquences économiques seront assez
forte pour le royaume-uni et aussi pour
l'europe
et ça il faut s'en inquiéter marin de
viry est ce que le l'écrivain que vous
êtes est sensible aux cats hermann est
ce que cette situation où le royaume uni
fonce vers l'inconnu à tombeau ouvert
dans la nuit sans fard et avec un
dirigeant parce que j'ai cru que je
crois qu'il ne fait pas de doute qu'il
sera premier ministre puisque maintenant
on est dans la phase où après que les
parlementaires aient voté cette année
milan les militants conservateurs qui
vont voter y en à peu près 150 nuits je
crois que les sondages au sein des
militants conservateurs sont bons pour
pour boris johnson le psycho type si je
peux dire donc le psycho type enfin le
type psychologique de
boris johnson et finalement très très
anglais assez typique avec peut-être une
nuance d'orientalisme si je peux dire
parce qu'elles sont mariées grand-père
et sept ministres de la sublime porte
absolument tout à fait est bon c'est un
type qui je crois felton oxford qui
connaît bien la culture classique mais
c'est pas du tout robe quoi il s'est
passé beaucoup plus profond du point de
vue de la culture générale du point de
vue l'intelligence est quand même
coiffeur non ils n'ont pas pas ils
pourraient et c'est probablement un
homme extraordinairement intelligent qui
n'est pas la moindre idée de la méthode
avec laquelle il va aborder la période
critique avant le 31 octobre
ça me paraît pas tout à fait clair mais
qu'il l'a et puis peut quand même
s'appuyer sur une diplomatie anglaise
qui peut même très préparée et qui
connaît parfaitement bruxelles donc je
sais pas je suis plutôt pas inquiétant
mini la personne de sa personnalité ne
m'inquiète pas la diplomatie anglaise a
des ressources insoupçonnées et le
l'europe cherchera un accord donc
pourquoi est-ce que vous font ou ont
fait un drame de cette histoire là
puisque après tout les anglais ont des
modes démocratiquement tranché je vois
la goutte est pourquoi il faut être
inquiet aussi il sait pas parce que il
ya toujours ce perspective éventuelle
d'un deuxième référendum ou pas et même
si on a un deuxième référendum et il est
britannique vote pour rester dans
l'union européenne par exemple très bien
si britanniques votent pour partie de
l'union européenne peu une deuxième fois
dans le même temps même sens
les divisions dans le pays manon sont
tellement profondes entre les peaux et
les gronde et les je ne sais pas
exactement ce que je pense il va falloir
même si on reste dans l'union européenne
les divisions sont déjà créées pour que
ça dure prônons des décennies après
propos que ce avant que ça soit 6,4 y y
et c'est ça c'est ça qui est grave pour
la grande-bretagne savait que le peuple
est complètement des viseurs un tel
point qu'il ya des gens qui se parlent
plus à caudry bright et et je ne vois
difficilement au clan politique que ce
soit un homme ou une femme de gauche de
droite ou de n'importe quel plongeon
politiques qui seront capables de
présenter un programme qui va cicatriser
ce problème est malheureusement
pollution c'est très mal classé pour y
arriver ou pas presque enfin il va de
soi que l'europe est un être un sujet de
guerre civile par des finales il a fait
ce qu au fond c'est un conflit de
loyauté quoi où on est
anglet où on est anglais l'européen où
on est français ou on est un repère
nommé c'est comme ça que les choses se
présentent psycho politiquement si je
peux dire pour le pour le aujourd'hui on
le voit bien méchant si ça va bien
s'ils sont aussi en sombrant à la fin du
mois d'octobre et ça se passe très bien
à l'économie rebond ou l'expulsion
images restent au niveau actuel et aussi
des tags contrat à travers le monde avec
des tas de d'entreprises comme on
voudrait et on a la libration de
marchandises avec l'union européenne
et tu va très bien madame la marquise je
pense que les la cicatrice c'est en
moins profondes
mais si ça va mal qu'il est faux le cas
si on passe on deale là je pense que on
est vraiment face à une très grave crise
en grande bretagne même contre ce peuple
tellement divisée
juste un point qui me chagrine c'est que
tout ça a commencé à l'intérieur du
parti conservateur
et tout cela finit à l'intérieur du
parti conservateur droit dit c'est un
parti politique qui a mis le royaume uni
dans cet état est dans cette situation
si ça ça n'est pas le symptôme criant
d'une décomposition du paysage politique
en cours alors je ne vois plus clair du
tout il est évident qu'il doit y avoir
une opération de clarification politique
à cette occasion le break site n'est pas
seulement une question de relations
entre le royaume uni et l'europe
ça n'est pas une crise mystique c'est
aussi de la basse politique et de cette
manière là monsieur johnson et son
avènement bientôt confirmée ne fait que
révéler une nouvelle fois que le royaume
uni traverse une crise de la
représentation politique à l'égal
d'autres pays de l'union
chaque pays ayant sa propre méthode de
décomposition et ses propres symptômes
de décomposition mais si on voit ça
comme ça mon avis c'est un peu moins
dramatique
il faudra aussi pendant que monsieur
johnson fera ses gesticulations que le
couple franco-allemand trouve une
nouvelle dynamique
qui n'est pas du tout du tout en cours
et pas du tout garanti
donc il y aura aussi d'autres problèmes
je crois qu'il faut essayer d'élargir la
focale et de dédramatiser un petit peu
cette situation année - là dessus oui on
ne lui parlait du parti conservateur
c'est très vrai ce que ce que vous dites
il faut regarder aussi l'opposition face
est assez tout aussi divisés
c'est à dire que jeremy corbineau on n'a
aucune idée de ce qu'il veut faire du
bric site à chaque fois qu'on lui pose
la question je vois qu'un journaliste
récemment lui a posé 11 fois la question
de suite il était incapable de répondre
si oui ou non le royaume il devait
quitter l'union européenne et comment
est donc en fait la plus grande chance
de boris johnson quelque part le dernier
arrière chose à laquelle il peut se
raccrocher
c'est le fait que l'opposition est
complètement incapable de gérer ce cette
situation non plus donc c'est peut-être
mieux d'avoir johnson que corby entre la
peste et le choléra je sais pas il faut
faut choisir
mais quelque part l'opposition a elle
aussi une très grande responsabilité
dans la situation actuelle merci un
dernier mot que nous laisserons à nos
internautes à citoyens qui nous dit
johnson est tout à fait compatible avec
le break site
on revient aux fondamentaux on s'en va à
l'union européenne
et voilà tandis qu'eric ne comprends pas
comment les anglais peuvent voter pour
cet homme qui les a menés en bateau avec
le break site auquel il était on le
rappelle extrêmement favorable nous
allons revenir en france pour parler de
cette affaire du burkini dimanche
dernier une dizaine de femmes
vêtu de cette tenue couvrant
intégralement et permettant néanmoins de
se baigner elles ont pénétré dans la
piscine jean bron c'est à grenoble
elle avait confié les journalistes pour
immortaliser ce moment le maire europe
écologie de grenoble qui est partie
prenante puisqu'il s'agissait d'une
piscine municipale est intervenue hier
sur bfm tv pour dire ce qu'il en pensait
et en fait il n'est pas très à l'aise
sur la laïcité dans l'espace public
parce que là on est dans un service
public standard et est donc il faut
qu'on ait ce débat qui est un débat qui
concerne la nation autour de la laïcité
bon pourquoi pas on a vu ce qu'il en est
et soleil sur les plages l'été dernier à
tous les arrêtés ont été cassée par le
conseil d'état ou bien on regarde juste
l'hygiène et la sécurité et à ce moment
là il faut poser les termes d'un
dialogue serein
voilà est le même maire de grenoble a
annoncé qu' il ne modifierait pas le
règlement intérieur des piscines cet été
alors le burqini n'est pas autorisée
mais pour des raisons d'hygiène va pour
des raisons de laïcité
écoutez maintenant un point de vue un
peu plus de trancher ou en tout cas en
faveur de l'interdiction celui d'eric
diarra lors il est député les
républicains des bouches du rhône il est
par ailleurs rapporteur de la mission
d'information sur la radicalisation dans
les services publics dont le figaro a
publié ce matin
de larges extraits les d'un retrait du
rapport publié par cette mission
d'information est par ailleurs il a été
maire de sausset les pins
c'est donc dans les bouches du rhône et
à l'époque il avait pris un arrêté anti
burqini et voilà pourquoi il convient
selon lui de l'interdire le burqini
poser problème premièrement ce mur qui
n'y existe depuis peu c'est pas une
tradition ancestrale où une tradition
religieuse
deuxièmement y pose des problèmes
d'hygiène moi si je vais à la piscine et
que je mets un short de surf je me fais
virer il pose des problèmes de sécurité
c'est ce que me disaient les sauveteurs
c'est à dire si vous me noyer tout
habillé vous posez beaucoup plus lourd
que lorsque vous êtes en maillot de bain
et
il pose des problèmes d'atteinte à la
laïcité voilà et avant de lancer le
débat je vous propose de de prendre
connaissance de cette de ce propos du
ministère des sports qui a fait un point
un petit peu juridique sur ce sujet en
disant que les personnes qui fréquentent
une piscine municipale sont des usagers
du service public vis-à-vis desquels il
n'existe pas de législation restrictive
quant au port d'une tenue qui
s'apparenterait à un motif religieux
en d'autres termes on peut parler de
leur interdire puisque la liberté de
conscience prime
en revanche on pourrait interdire le
burqini sur la base de raisons
objectives telles que l'hygiène ou la
sécurité
alors nos internautes ce qu'ils sont en
train de nous suivre
honteux en aviez assez tranché sur la
question puisque ils sont à 92 %
favorables à une loi ou oui ce serait
probablement une loi pour interdire le
burqini dans les piscines municipales
marin de viry vous avez un point de vue
sur ce sujet oui
d'abord c'était une opération c'était
une opération qui n'était pas au top de
mon innocence et une opération militante
j'ai l'impression de faire plusieurs
personnes arrivent en même temps dans
une certaine tenue dans un endroit
public
cette opération elle avait donc pour but
d'essayer de j'imagine de généraliser ce
fait enfin de faire en sorte qu'il y est
une autorisation générale une tolérance
super prend donc du coup enfin c'est une
forme de prosélytisme vestimentaires si
vous voulez qu'ils moi ne me convient
pas du tout mais alors pas du tout cette
espèce que c'est au fond c'est une sorte
de mur car aquatique ce truc là donc il
ya quelque chose de me déclarer chose de
très agressif
elle n'est pas être rejoué mais à
quelque chose de très agressif de très
agressif de très prosélyte et donc sera
pas donc ni pour les femmes ni pour les
hommes ni pour la république ni pour
l'espace public ni pour les jeunes ni
pour la sécurité lit pour la laïcité il
faut l'accepter
voilà qu'il faut être vraiment
extrêmement ferme avec 7 avec sort on
rappellera qu'un notre épisode de ce
type avaient eu lieu au mad mais dans
une autre piscine de grenoble avec la
même organisation
philippe tort vous connaissez la
réglementation en angleterre est ce
qu'on voit des femmes au burkina on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes musulmanes
autre manche quand vous épluchez la
presse britannique selon le plan
clinique est ce que vous voyez où et que
les histoires qui concerne la france en
grande bretagne a pas de législation a
pas de règle en ordre pour cela donc on
est libre de faire ce qu'on veut pour le
moment il n'y a pas eu de règlement et
je pense que c'est un problème qui à ma
connaissance a été moins visible en
grande bretagne qu'en france ok a fait
moins de bruit que certaines banques en
france sont le fond je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous moi quand je vais à
la piscine
ce qui passait souvent mais quand j'y
vais on m'impose un bonnet sur la tête
on m'impose un vrai maillot de bain ya
pas de shorts de bain donc j'accepte la
réglementation et et voilà j'y veille si
je n'accepte pas j'y vais pas c'est
simple mais je pense que là on a des cas
individuels en france certaines villes
qui l'on interdit mais a pas de
législation générale là je pense qu'il
est temps que l'état intervienne pour
que ce soit clair parce que là on est
dans une espèce de flou concernant les
règlements
est-ce que ça fait partie de la laïcité
ou pas est ce que la vie a le droit
d'entrée d'air ou pas est-ce que
une interdiction va être ensuite
interdit parce que c'est contre la loi
tout ça c'est très peu et je pense que
quand j'ai lu ce matin le l'excellente
est détruit à dos figure au pays créant
sur le fait que le gouvernement a traîné
la patte vis-à-vis de l'administration
contre ce genre de pratique voilà je
pense qu'il est con comme elle que
l'état intervienne pour fanny clair dans
cette histoire parce que là ça ouvre la
porte
partout à ce genre de pratique les
jeunes tafer n'a moyens pas de
discussion générale
donc on est dans notre droit on fait un
coup point quelque part pour pour donner
notre avis ici c'est interdit
portefeuille pourrait plus maximis bay
est ce que le libéral que vous êtes cons
se dire que chacun doit pouvoir
finalement s'habiller comme ils